what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here joined by
Michael the Tesla a Star Wars Professor
I'm gonna start calling you that instead
listen so we already covered the Ahsoka
trailer leave a like by the way please
go ahead use the force label like you
know how we did we already covered the
Ahsoka trailer you guys go ahead and
watch that now they did announce some
stuff from Star Wars when I called
Michael this morning like where you got
Michael I always had a Soaker trailer
was out and I asked him like don't read
anything of what's announced man I heard
about the Ahsoka trailer and I heard of
one movie but I heard there's three
actually so I don't know any specifics I
literally just saw a title of something
and I was like oh wow that's all I got
I'm like nervous so here we go Michael
so I have this IGN article pulled up
here yeah lucasfilm announces three live
action Star Wars movies or in
development with directors Dave baloney
James Mangold and Charmaine obey chenoy
James mangle director of Star Wars
remember he was in talk they were
talking about him doing like Boba Fett
oh God I would have paid a lot of money
for that version great Dave filoni's
film will focus on the new Republic and
as a big deal as felony has been an
integral part of Star Wars for many
years okay so proud and happy for him I
did hear that his movie is going to take
place that is one of the things I saw
would take place after uh episode six
before episode seven amazing so as we
have all been thinking building up to
that big cinematic event yeah to tie it
into here
that Gap with like Mandalorian and
Ahsoka right what a task did you read
this Michael
oh my God Daisy really returning to Star
Wars in a movie set after the rise of
Skywalker as mentioned in the blurb
above Daisy Ridley will officially be
returning to Star Wars Rey in a new
movie set 15 years I didn't know that
after the events arise of Skywalker wow
in this new movie oh that's the one
directed by Charmaine Rey will attempt
to rebuild the Jedi Order as a Jedi
master so we can get more Jedi movies
it's almost like what we wanted the
first time yeah yeah while I am
skeptical of anything in the sequel era
I personally feel like uh Daisy Ridley
John boyega oh damarin
[Laughter]
so beautiful the talent that they found
were so good I'm really excited for all
of them to have the opportunity to like
really really do what they do best I'm
impressed and surprised in equal measure
I think the gut instinct for Disney was
to like never talk or think about the
sequels again and and I appreciate that
with a bit of time a bit of refinement
that we can give maybe some of this
amazing cast uh the opportunity to
really shine do you think John boyega
will return I hope he does oh oh me too
I think that of all them jumbo got the
absolute crap end of the stairs set up
and they just totally put them like if
they don't open with him as a Jedi
Knight I'll be real angry I also want to
know what happened with the kid with the
broom yeah is he still sweeping
somewhere uh using his limited Force
capability it's just a sweet but no
especially for Daisy Ridley where it's
like rise of Skywalker especially was so
pan but I feel like she really poured
her heart and soul into those movies and
regardless of what you think about those
films I think Daisy Ridley did excellent
work it's the kind of thing kind of like
what we see with the guy who plays Jar
Jar Binks on that best I love that
you're comparing Rey into the judge our
picture
of the idea of like oh man this person
has such like a negative relationship
with Star Wars and now they get a chance
to redeem themselves yeah and do
something special and different I'm
excited to see where they go with it I'm
super curious because you know with with
Palpatine gone again for the a couple
times now who is the big bad like I'm
I'm curious are they going to go down
the same old Rabbit Hole or are we going
to introduce something new well that's
what I find cool about it is because
it's saying that's focused on her
billion Jedi Master building a new order
they would be doing like a continuation
it's not a fill in the Gap a segment of
Star Wars they'd be doing something that
takes place after the main Skywalker
Saga but it wouldn't be epic so 10 you
know yeah and I think that's a really
cool direction to do it because this
would be the first time we have
something that takes place after
Skywalker Saga that is not an episode
something it would be its own thing
maybe I'm presuming it might be episode
10 yeah and it's an unexplored well she
is a Skywalker yeah sure she is a race
it's an unexplored time period the thing
that I'm genuinely most excited about in
Star Wars right now is that for the
first time in forever we have like an
ominous villain that exists without out
of the realm of anything that we've ever
dealt with or anything that we've ever
seen in in the form of you know the
potentially the grisk uh in in Ahsoka
getting out of just the Jedi and the
step is really exciting so is it going
to be called the new new Republic yeah
the newer Republic the newest Republic
okay yeah so they do confirm that
filoni's movie will take place after the
events of the Return of the Jedi before
Force awakens it will close out the
interconnected stories told in the
Mandalorian book of Boba Fett Ahsoka and
other New Republic focused Disney plus
series looks like they want to conclude
the shows that are doing some of the
best for Star Wars right now well for
now yeah I'm sure they'll find a way to
give every secondary character their own
spin-off from that but I think it's just
great that Dave filoni is finally
getting a chance to make a movie I mean
we've talked about it forever of of
giving him that mantle and and the
creative Liberty I mean based on what we
saw from the Ahsoka trailer it's hard
not to imagine it's gonna be a crazy
Star Wars movie I mean just that one
episode he did of season two was
phenomenal one of my favorites of the
whole series he just has such a great
attention to George's original Vision
he's such a cinephile and from so many
different cultures and perspectives and
he really just like pulls the best of
everything which I feel like Star Wars
at its heart is just this like
collection of great of other movies yeah
all kind of put together with this like
amazing lore glue that nobody knows
better than Dave filoni well you see
that's the funny thing with that episode
six that came out of the Mandalorian
there were a lot of people were like
it's like a Clone Wars episode it's like
a cloners episode and to me I you know
and I think of Clone Wars like sure are
there some goofy silly fun episodes
Absolutely but there's also some of the
most intense most serious some of the
best Star Wars has ever been yeah from
clone wars that my mind immediately goes
to like that was some of the most
gripped I've ever been and it wasn't a
goofy thing at all and then with James
mangold's movie what they have here is
it's going to take place at an early
point in the Star Wars timeline we came
up with an incredible story to tell
about the dawning of the force okay
whoa yeah I mean I'm I know they put a
lot of time and energy into like well
the high Republic period I think Star
Wars fans forever uh since the Knights
of the Old Republic video game series
came out forever and ever ago to see the
origins and to see the beginning and
there's so much like how did everything
take shape like how did the first like
Sith be like break from the Jedi and the
Jedi Civil War I mean I'm really curious
as to what time period exactly they're
going to cover because some of it is
Canon other parts are not yet defined
it's just exciting to I want to see
coruscantes Rock when it was just a rock
what if that's the whole movie it's just
like an ethereal well he's like he's
like on a mission or she is on a mission
uh to like find the force they climb
this mountain and at the very end we cut
two and it's just Pershing licking the
lollipop whoa it's the same man well in
Clone Wars we had the mortise are and
that really seemed to delve deep into
[Music]
yeah yeah I mean it's every time I think
I've wrapped my head around what they
think the force is they continue to
didn't dig a Little Deeper it would be
really neat to go back to some locations
that we've seen you know some of the
ancient sites like sure where we picked
up with with Luke
uh in force awakens skelos uh which is
the actual name of the island that'd be
so cool to see that like as like an
actual Jedi Temple or to like see the
building of the original Jedi Temple and
Coruscant like stuff like that does it
for minority self well man there's
a lot here there's a lot which one are
you most excited for my my gut says Dave
filoni in my opinion is the most
deserving wonderful Soul people in the
film World kind of look down on
television I feel like people in the
television world look down on animation
Dave filoni if you think about his like
rise and Ascension and his ability to
honor George's original Vision while
also like embracing the fans and hearing
them and evolving and growing as a
Storyteller I just feel like he's going
to tell a story that is the culmination
of his entire Star Wars career thus far
I mean all of these dots are threaded
together I think that's a pretty
extraordinary thing and regardless of if
it's my favorite Star Wars movie I think
it's the one I'm most excited for
because it's nice to see somebody who
genuinely loves this and lives it in the
same way I think a lot of Star Wars fans
do finally have that chance to really
play with the big boys I mean directing
a Star Wars film is no joke yeah the
other one sounded really fun though I'm
really jazzed alrighty guys well which
one of these announcements are you most
excited for leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe leave a like
keep a look out for our Mandalorian
reaction to the force I'll see you guys
soon
[Music]